we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192
david p here's a funny voicemail i get
that this is a joke
but there's actually something very
serious in it take a listen
hey david tim from chicago here so
joe biden keeps talking about unity and
all that
i mean unity would be really nice but
you know who's going to pay for it
right you know he just took office
and this deficit is already at 27
trillion dollars right
who's going to pay for all this unity
yeah now to be clear
the deficit isn't 27 trillion
it's the debt and the debt is also not
27 trillion it's 23 trillion so
important details
the debt is 23 trillion but the caller
makes a good point which is
does biden get blamed for the 400 000
coronavirus deaths starting today by
right-wing media
does biden get blamed for the deficit
that trump exploded starting today and
obviously you and i realize that after
being in office 24 hours
those things are not yet your fault or
responsibility
but the right is going to go with that
sean hannity already doing a segment
last night saying
you know why isn't biden doing more on
kovid they said they were going to do
kovadkovakova on day one
he hasn't done that much that was a
broadcast uh
nine hours after joe biden had been
sworn in so
i know the caller's kidding but they
aren't kidding they're really going to
start doing that and this is why again
if there's republican infighting that
distracts them
it's only good for joe biden's ability
to get things done
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today we will talk about the bernie
sanders mittens meme that has exploded
since the inauguration we are going to
talk about north carolina okaying
uh a ban on hairstyle
discrimination very interesting and we
will also talk about
men leaving college faster than women
during the pandemic
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member at
joinpakman.com